[Musique]
à quelques jours du départ du Grand Raid
le département a rassemblé les acteurs
de la préservation du patrimoine naturel
au palais de la source ce lundi 17
octobre à l'heure des 30 ans des espaces
naturels sensibles ce rendez-vous fut
l'occasion de rappeler le rôle de la
collectivité en tant que chef de fil du
sport de nature et premier propriétaire
forestier de Lille c'est le 30e
anniversaire du Grand Raid mais c'est
aussi 30 ans d'engagement de la part du
département dans tout ce qui est
protection préservation de nos espaces
naturels sensibles et lorsque nous avons
ce plaisir de dire que la Réunion
accueille quand même la 2e ou 3e poisse
de montagne la plus grande du monde et
bien nous sommes heureux de en tant que
partenaire de participer à cette belle
réussite je voudrais laisser la parole à
à vice-président délégué à notamment
l'environnement et à aussi notre
conseiller départemental qui est très
engagé dans tout ce qui est sport nature
je voulais saluer
l'exemplarité de l'association grand
raid pour cette nouvelle édition bien
évidemment féliciter les équipes de
gestionnaires et tous les partenaires
qui travaille d'arrache-pied au
quotidien tout tout le long de l'année
pour entretenir nos sentiers il faut
savoir que le département est
propriétaire de 95 % des forêts et de
plus de et entretient plus de 800 km de
sentier donc bien évidemment on est un
acteur privilégié et nous sommes ravis
aujourd'hui de fêter ce 30e anniversaire
des espaces naturels sensible au même
moment que celui du Grand Raid voilà
alors le département donc qui est chef
de fil en terme de sport de nature on ne
peut pas pratiquer sans penser à
conserver et à entretenir et valoriser
donc nos espaces pour faire de de cette
fête et de cette aventure vraiment un un
exemple pour pour toutes les autres
pratiques de sport de nature dans notre
dans notre île afin que bah on n'est pas
cette image de je pratique je consomme
et je jette bien au contraire le
département accompagne donc le Grand
Raid sur sur ces éditions en prenant
conscience justement qu'il faut
absolument
euh perdurer et euh valoriser donc nos
espaces et je voudrais dire que le
département et bien sûr très présent à
travers une équipe de six coureurs mais
aussi à travers des stand au départ et à
l'arrivée l'occasion de montrer ce que
nous faisons comme on l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure à travers donc nos programmes de
protection de valorisation des S mais
c'est aussi de saluer le travail des
agents qui tout au long de l'année
entretiennent et bien ces sentiers de
randonné vivre cette nouvelle édition
que le meilleur gagne mais en tout cas
l'intérêt de tout à chacun c'est déjà
d'y participer alors bravo à parmi les
6500 coureurs inscrits si agents du
Département prendront le départ de la
course ben comme c'était un défi que
cour sur les routes après la personne
dit Mo coup la montagne commencé au mois
de février là cette année et là depuis
mois de février jusqu'à aujourd'hui en
montagne avec eu la chance de rencontrer
des amis que dans une team
permett à Mo don des conseils d'avancer
parce que tout seul nur pas pas pu
stressé parce
que le stress m pasis à gérer vra que
nous fait fait l'alimentation mais le
stress comme c'est mon premier et
que de MO beaucoup d'attente dessus du
coup est-ce que sera à la hauteur ou
pass la fin finir mais pense que pour je
les connais pas mais c'est n pas facile
le stress cette édition anniversaire met
à l'honneur la préservation de la nature
un travail de sensibilisation du public
aux pratiques écoresponsables sera mené
par les collégiens de l'UNSS avec
l'appui des différents bénévoles
présents sur
[Musique]
l'événement